20 string methods first one care at this
returns the character that specified
position if you look on the console we
apart because it's care at index one if
we go to string one when it starts with
index 0 then index 1 is our now we have
care code yet this returns the Unicode
of the character at the specified index
and now we have 114 that's the Unicode
character of our from let's run right
here Concannon returns a new joined
string so we put the first string and
then concatenate in the parentheses and
then we get free code camp is the best
place to learn front end and back in
development you'll notice that there's
no space here because there's no space
in between these two strings ends with
checks whether a string ends with a
specified string or characters so if we
have learned in here in the console is
going to show true if we put 2 in here
it's going to show false because string
1 ends with the word learn and it does
not end with the word - ok from care
code this converts Unicode values to
characters this is a static method of
the string object so this is the first
one that we're not starting with a
string or a string variable like string
1 and all the other examples this time
you have to put the actual string object
string dot from care code and then you
put the Unicode character right here so
let's run that and we can see our
because if you look up here we know that
kira code at 1 is 114 so I just put 114
in here and we get our again now we have
includes this checks whether a string
contains the specified string a
character so would you include we can
see it is true because string 2 does
include the word end it actually has the
word end two times because it's
front-end and back-end development ok
index of returns the position of the
first found occurrence of a specified
value in a string if we do string two
index up in order to end we're going to
get the number five so let's go back up
the string up here let's see 0 1
two three four five and at the fifth
index is where we start the word end
even though you can see the end is
actually in that string two times but
we're only giving the index of the first
time
next up last index of that's pretty
similar so for last index up we're going
to return the position of the last found
occurrence with a specified value in a
string so we have 17 that's going to be
the last word end because remember that
word end is two times so this is the
index number seventeen here
so this is the first found this is the
last found four index of and last index
of okay now we have match match is going
to search a string for a match against a
regular expression and return the
matches so we got strength to match
here's the regular expression and if we
run that it's going to be actually an
array of each match so the word end is
is actually in strength two two times so
there's gonna be array with the word end
twice in the array check the description
for a link to more information about
regular expressions repeat is going to
return a new string with a specified
number of copies of an existing string
if you looked at the bottom of the
console it's a three Co campuses best
place to learn one two and three times
because we have string one or EP and I
put three next is replace replace
searches a string for a specified value
or regular expression and returns a new
string where the specified values are so
we have got the string through that
replace we did the same regex from above
but and now we're going to replace with
all capital letters so if you look at
what we get out here front-end and
back-end development the end is all
capitalized okay now we're going to do
search here the search is going to
search a string for a specified value or
regular expression and return the
position of the match so we did string
to search end and we can see that the
position of the word end is an index
five slice is going to extract a part of
the string and return a new string so if
we run that it's going to start at two
that's going to the first index
and then four is going to be the index
after it ends so you can see we got the
word on here so if you look up here 0 1
2 this is we're going to start the
letter O and then 3 4 the 4th index is
going to be the next after it ends so
we're just going to have the word on
okay split is going to split a string
into an array of sub strings when I call
the split method I'm going to pass in
the character that you want the string
to be split on I'm going to split on
spaces so it's going to be an array of
each word in the string if I look at the
bottom you can see there's an array of
each word in the string because it's
what that string on the spaces now
starts with is going to check whether a
string begins with specified characters
so let's check if string 1 begins with
the characters fr EE if we look at the
bottom of the console true because it
does begin with the characters fr EE sub
STR sub straw is kind of like slice it's
going to extract the characters from a
string beginning at a specified start
position and through the number of
characters so we can see we started at 2
and then want to go for 4 characters and
so it's going to start if you look up
here this is the to remember for slice
we start with 2 and then we ended with
the 4th index but here we're starting
with 2 and we're just counting four
characters so you can see there's gonna
be four characters Ont e.substring is
also similar it's going to extract the
characters from a string between two
specified indexes so let's run that and
you can see it's very similar to slice
we get we're starting with index 2 and
then we're going to count we're not
going to count 4 we're going to go to
index 4 and 4 is going be the last index
to lowercase is pretty self-explanatory
makes the string all lowercase letters
if you look over in the console now
before free code campus and capital
letters but now that we've run to
lowercase
there is no capital letters now to
uppercase is going to make all the
letters uppercase in the string okay the
last one is trim trim is going to remove
whitespace from either side of the
string so now we have a new
string string three and you can see
there's all these spaces and it says
subscribe now and then there's all these
spaces again so if we call string three
trim it's going to say subscribe now and
there's not many spaces in there okay
well thanks for watching my name is beau
Carnes don't forget to subscribe and
remember use your code for good